marvel fans on reddit have a theory that
the events of thor the dark world may
have played a role in jane foster's
deadly medical diagnosis in love and
thunder fans will recall that jane
briefly played host to the reality stone
also called the aether in the thor
sequel the aether was later extracted
from jane's body to malekith before
eventually being handed off to the
collector for safe keeping and then
later acquired by thanos in avengers
infinity war as its name suggests the
reality stone is capable of disrupting
the laws of physics but is also an
incredibly powerful object that has
proven harmful to those who come into
contact with it as the theory goes
jane's cancer diagnosis in love and
thunder could be traced back to this
encounter and while it's not confirmed
in the film the theory does make sense
on the other hand jane's diagnosis could
come down to genetics as we see that her
mother passed away from an illness
during a flashback scene in the film so
what do you think